thank you for calling the Red Lobster
for takeout first one favorite call
Washington's lobster day how may I help
you
oh yeah I'll go to place an order please
a dozen a dozen of the cheesy biscuits I
was wondering how much is it for are the
cheesy biscuits for takeout does it I
think it's like less than five dollars
okay you only have to Cola head for that
is that something I'll could just come
in and get what time were you planning
on coming in probably within like 15 20
minutes okay I'll go pull some for you
he's a little bit behind right now so
you might just other way like a minute
or two but I'll gonna make sure she
knows you're coming
okay that's great thank you you're
welcome oh boy what
I'll just slip hi yes can I get an hour
Oprah chai latte iced your tea
oh that's it please thank you okay let
me pay for my Starbucks test that Keith
why you're dressed like that
oh I ordered some biscuits from Red
Lobster let's get some from Red Lobster
so I'm going to pick them up booze
you're having five dear thank you yeah
okay oh oh goodness
got me hold up great thing a lot will
get a picture with mono friends they say
they won't take picture with me I hope I
don't get stabbed
this lot of poachers are here they're
drunk fishing for more Colin I hope
they're just friendly folk yeah though I
were just hello hello all right
hello you can call me Libby okay live it
a lot of lobster okay thank you haven't
I say
I might as well destroy I mean we're all
away you know can't believe I'll meet
some friends today it's almost like it's
almost like in the sea you just be
swimming and you may die hey we'll see
you there
come on you've GPS GPS looks a little
bit different when you're under the sea
the seaweed is always greener and
somebody else's leg but the irony of all
of this is we are not in a lake I also
don't have any see we only currently are
if - yeah really all right
oh so off don't have Africa oh my
goodness we exactly is it go go up okay
elderly and then go is that eight well
there she wrecked my car oh my goodness
all right there it is yes she is ladies
and gentlemen look a real built red
today
Red Lobster my god something that makes
me nervous when I'm here I just never
know what's gonna happen
I have a lot of my friends are in there
but they're not actually my friends cuz
they I usually take the ones that are
not the nice the nice lobsters if you
know what I mean like me I'd be a such a
prime catch
I've real media around the center is
they'll take out parking this is this is
this is such bollocks
once when I was here it was it was art
was for a birthday party the crazy thing
about this birthday party was the friend
that we were celebrating was actually he
was already in the tank I've gotta find
a place all right here I'm gonna pop
right get hurt right there in front of
you okay straight do you think that yes
what overall here no park right there
why do you look like that because it's
what we for the restaurant there's no
one literally right well I've got right
here
oh geez goodness I think about bringing
lobsters you don't have much turning
radius for your neck as you guys call
them here oh my goodness all right
it's almost time here hey do you think I
won't be able to borrow $10 please thank
you yet it'll confuse cuz where I'm from
we drive on the other side so also new
to me
oh yeah might want my keys
hi hello I ordered a 12 biscuits to go
you go right up to the bar right thank
you
I did yes sorry biscuit
here you go thank you
okay thank you help miss okay every mom
is it my hair this is quite right
are you using your claws like that yeah
oh just I just got will go like this and
then I just go like you well I run a lot
the cheesy biscuits but I'm not too fond
of the lobsters okay I'm a vegetarian
okay yes yes in your bedroom yes that's
crazy
am I going out I just want to leave a
tip but I'm not so good so good at
counting some points
okay
thank you